in rural Northeastern Brazil people
don't often receive visitors except
during election time
that's when 83 year old Sebastian and
his son say they can always be sure to
be called on by candidates for municipal
and federal office just last week 32
year old gilesson says he was working
right here making his clay pots when
they were visited and offered between
two and ten dollars for their votes
they come here start to talk to us and
say vote for me then they put their
hands in their pockets and give you the
money since the person is in need they
take it you see
Sebastian says candidates also offer
water which is scarce here or
construction material or clay but that
after the elections when you ask for
their help they send you away saying
they've already paid for your vote
last time did you vote for the person
who paid you I asked
sure I accepted favor and then I voted
for whoever I wanted
[Laughter]
to give them handouts
an old practice but in times of economic
hardship like now it's even more
difficult to resist
from here until Election Day Day and
Night they don't stop buying votes we
know that in exchange they sometimes
offer water a basic food basket money
sandals and even Dentures 43 year old
farmer Sylvia josefa Da Costa says
candidates have been coming all week but
that she doesn't accept their overtures
not since she was traumatized by an
offer of a municipal job
may I speak frankly in exchange for that
he wanted me to stay with him do you
understand so in my case it wasn't even
food it was for me to offer myself to
him
the penalty for buying or selling votes
is high but electoral tribunal
authorities concede it's difficult to
combat
nowadays very few cases are reported we
need to change water Behavior because
the water who tries to sell his road or
has his vote corrupted won't denounce
himself
Financial incentives for voting are more
common in Municipal elections but not
exclusively incumbent candidates all the
way up to the presidency have the
advantage perhaps the most obvious
example is President Jade bolsonaro's
decision to distribute a hundred and
twenty dollars to Brazilian families
most in need for the next four months
even though the Constitution
specifically bars governments from
Distributing money on the eve of
Elections
president bolsonaro declared a state of
emergency to get around the prohibition
money and other handouts are always
welcome by the poor even during
elections but many ask at what price for
Brazil's democracy
to see a human Al Jazeera